wir machen einfach mal so eine kleine
challenge lasst uns einfach mal so
machen dass wir sagen wir dürfen im
deathmatch kein schwert verwenden oder
er macht mir leichter macht vielleicht
aber vielleicht ja ja ja ja ja nein nein
nein
davos erst zuletzt wir kommen zu einem
neuen video und heute machen wir was wir
schon lange lange nicht mehr gemacht
haben und zwar ganz ohne aufgeregt
spielend einfach hier noch schöne runde
sg und ich werde euch dazu dinge aus dem
beleben kommentieren und über dinge
reden gerade sehr wichtig sind nicht
naja gut also es gibt momentan schon
echt paar stressige sachen weil wir
deswegen ich auch diese fünf tage
letztes profi traders glaube ich vier
tage lang keine videos bringen konnte
was aber daran lag dass ich in meiner
uni momentan extrem viel zu tun hat
steve kann zu haben der kampf soll
lustig er kam einfach gerade von hier
und da hätte ihn nicht bekommen habt
könnt ihr kam von da aus der wand ok
kann man kann man nichts machen
in jedem fall aufrecht sein alter eu in
der band oder keine ahnung
seine zweit dritt führt persönlichkeit
naja war ja genau wie seit juni relativ
stressig ist wird auch noch viel viel
stressiger als es in den letzten vier
tage war wenn meine klausurphase
anbricht wille mich gerade in dem
semester was am heftigsten ist an meiner
uni
deswegen muss ich mal schauen wie das
sein wird wenn ich dann links halten der
klausurphase wenn das kann ich jetzt
noch nicht sagen aber ich gehe mal davon
aus dass ich dann einfach nicht so
regelmäßig videos bringen werden kann
sehr schön gib mir mal deinen stein
schwert gibt immer die schuhe leisten so
kate hier noch das war jetzt manchmal
adressiert das thema und das ist durch
den starken max kind war okay ob man das
ist ein richtiger hype fehle einfach
klick klick klick klick und nicht auf
die gäste bestimmen aber die geistige
behinderung wieder ein bisschen einen
dämpfer die meisten leute spielen
bräuchte eigentlich ist mein kompass
manometer brauchen echte man kommt
passiert es kann so nicht weitergehen
ohne kompass
dann können wir gleich auf jeden fall
verdient überraschung mehr kein kompass
am nicht sieht auch ehrlich gesagt habe
ich ihn gesehen und ich hab ein bisschen
die dinger hat weiß ich ob er das war
oder ich aber ich glaube ich war sechs
megawatt blöcke hat einfach die dinger
da geöffnet jetzt haben ein kompass sehr
gut sehr gut aber kurz das hierher sagt
ja gut mit der axt kämpfe ich eigentlich
nicht so gern liebe mit dem schwert und
einer 2 level haben wir gute mann combo
zu geben er wird auch blockhütten von
bikern kommen ganz und gar nicht
erfordert unten links rechts oben und
nämlich drei level alter das ist richtig
krass das echt heftig richtig richtig
viel mit mir kurz das wegpacken dass ihr
das ihr dass ihr das hier schon ein
breiter frau weiß wie die leute
ausrasten kommt man unterhält sich
wieder durchatmen beim leben
ich hab's gefühl der nächste ich hab das
dumpfe gefühl dass sie gleich der
nächste kommt moment aber davon ist erst
mal keiner
ok jetzt ist mal wieder für drei kuchen
da können wir gleich uns schon im
deathmatch hoch stecken heute auf jeden
fall machen
in gold für ein pfeil und bogen dick
ausgerüstet ich würde ganz gerne wissen
wo der sport ist wie spielen übrigens
die map die für mich relativ neu ist
habe ich noch nie gespielt hier far away
heißt die glaube die ist schon ein paar
wochen hier oft den gomez server drauf
und zweimal treffen wo alter der svp
enchanted bisschen in cha cha cha cha
cha cha das entstand sehr gut wollen wir
doch mal gucken also man sagt ihr mann
kommt auf der map kann ich entspannter
dran aber wie ist das wenn man sich auf
dem kuchen hoch steckt dann kommt man
dran
ja und das ist neu es ist ein guter
trick hier eigentlich
das ist ein ganz guter text dann nehmt
mich in 120 fällen mit dem bogen die wir
dem geben können denn der spaß darf ich
dich hab hier sein leben nicht schreiben
kämpfen
ja oh mann ich treffe keine miene
wolter verdrängen dürfte er nicht
gesehen haben dass wir uns hier
allerdings gewinnt als oder spam
feuerwehrdepot uhr jetzt kommt da hinten
ja der ist nicht einfach den links
rechts noch mal sehr schön wunderbar
meine lieben leute alles klar
sehr schön gemacht jetzt noch ein
kleiner runde pixel games der fall auch
sein leben aber sehr gut gemacht raffin
ator ich wollte noch bisschen mehr in
chanten ehrlich gesagt waren jetzt nicht
gegönnt machen runde qi gong so da sind
wir eine fixe weile ganz ohne ich hab
mir die merten super-mario geforscht die
ihr soja in marie stil gehalten ist in
der name schon erahnen lässt ganz okay
ausrüstung angeht waffe ist gerade eher
schlecht hier eine sehr schön
luz skills sind nicht mehr so
optimistisch sagen oder stadt meist wird
komisch ist ein unikat gar nicht treffen
können was wir das mitbekommen habt habt
ihr das mit luca war wie schon auf das
video gut nachgedacht sebastian oder
kommt der nächste bitte nicht komme
schließlich runter sehr gerne kinder
handeln ja ja ja nichts anderes das ist
kacke wenn ich darüber spreche weil
wieder versuchen wir zu angeln aber er
kann sich weil es im monat jetzt rechnet
holen sagte wenn wir genauso sehr gut
okay soweit so gut
bisher eigentlich alles relativ gut wenn
den beiden runden ich muss jetzt nur die
erste games oder muss ich zwei versuche
starten meist nicht so gut lief aber
ansonsten ist das ja nicht alles mega
mega macht tnt wir im 8
und ich glaube ich mache mache einfach
mal so eine kleine challenge hab ich ein
bisschen bock drauf
lasst uns einfach mal so machen dass wir
sagen wir dürfen im deathmatch kein
schwert verwenden das heißt im
deathmatch wird nur mit club mate
bekämpft also pfeil und bogen tnt wenn
es denn sein muss
angel hotspur ist ja wie das ist kennt
das ja schon
hier ruht auf drei bis dahin darf ich
hier meine reisen schnell einsetzen aber
im deathmatch muss ich dann wegwerfen so
und ich bin mal sehr gespannt wie das
funktioniert ob man so eine kuh sg runde
ohne schwert gewinnen kann den threads
sie vor nicht wenn ich jetzt irgendwo
unter geschlagen oder selbst runter
fallen und man ist schon kommen die
gleichen loch im boden ich war unter
welchen nicht
ach da hinten seid ihr alle ja super
guck mal hier
du siehst nicht hoffentlich nicht wenn
ich mich jetzt an speicher doch nicht
jetzt kommt der andere auch noch ruhig
trefft grad eher wenig hier die pfeile
das bisschen doof ich weiß nicht mal ob
was denkt jetzt gefressen hat hier
drüben müsste man sich dann genau
anschauen
das hat eine momente wo ich ganz gern
oh mein gott oh mein gott das war so
knapp
alter und der nächste bitte bitte lass
mich leben dass mir so etwas auch er
kommt immer näher kommt immer näher
wo gott leute empfiehlt sich was wir im
stack feile wtf alter du weg davon
meinen sachen duale ganove so und jetzt
machen wir das death match ist
angekündigt hat komplett ohne schwert
schade dass eisen schwert werd ich bin
ich da hallo hallo wikis oder er macht
es mir leichter macht man leicht aber
vielleicht ja ja ja ja ja ja nein nein
nein ich bin ich bin ich bin ich mich
nämlich nein nein nein
seit altersher platz für den runterhauen
rückwärts nein
amis aber wir haben die technisch
gemacht
es zeigt auch die map war eigentlich
perfekt dafür werden darunter hätten
können
in die lava hätte ich machen müssen hat
nicht funktioniert leider misst na ja
auf jeden fall wirklich gefallen hat
könnt ihr gerne daumen nach oben da
lassen ansonsten was ist ansonsten
daumen oder nicht ich hoffe sie uns im
nächsten video wieder schreibt gerne in
die kommentare ob er vielleicht wieder
so ein kleiner chip serie haben wollt
ist eigentlich ein ganz witzige sache
und wenn dem so ist dass sie mehr
changes sehen wollte auf einem kanal
dann schreibt noch direkt welche in die
kommentare
würde ich mich sehr freuen und wenn ihr
bock drauf habt dann machen wir das im
nächsten video bis dahin macht's gut 30